[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
sachez aubry reconnaît preuve du jour
comptera donc deux points l'épreuve du
jour une balle de ping pong un gel
antibactérien il faudra jongler par
hasard c'est l'épreuve de très bons
alors non j'ai jamais fait les séries
[Musique]
à
le
e
tu es tout petit je vous ai vus jouer le
bas du tout pas du tout j'aimerais ça
faire peut vous l'envoyer en mer va
envoyer v club où je vais envoyer en
l'air frais du matin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et si tu es en finale avant de série on
va dire ce soir pour me dire que tu as
l'impression d'être à l'école est qu une
classe difficile aux tirs au but 3-2 à
top
vraiment envie 1910
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
arrivé
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]